Now remember, when we calculate the z score of any value in the distribution,
we first subtract the mean which shifts the distribution without changing the
shape so that zero is now the mean. And when we divide by the standard
deviation, we then change the shape. Let's look at it this way. We have any
distribution, with mean, mu, and standard deviation, sigma. Which basically
means that sigma is one standard deviation away from the mean. After we
standardize this distribution, what is going to be the z-score of sigma? Well,
remember when we subtract mu, we shift it so that mu is now zero. So now, the
z-score of sigma is going to be sigma minus zero divided by sigma, which is
sigma divided by sigma, which is 1. So, the z-score of any value, that's one
standard deviation away from the mean, will then be 1 after we standardize it.
Which means that the new standard deviation of this normalized distribution, or
standard distribution, is 1.